quand on place le robot il avance tout
seul parce que sur les lignes noires et
chaque code correspond à un mouvement
programmés
c'est pas sorcier à en croire edgar 11
ans qui a toujours aimé comprendre
comment les choses fonctionnent quand
j'étais un peu plus petit encore que ma
mère elle m'a verges tard et vous vous y
avait beaucoup de machines comme ça
qu'ils étaient expliquées les portail
automatisé le grille pain etc
et j'aimerais bien savoir comment ça
marche marine adore aussi
alors quand on lui a dit qu'elle allait
pouvoir programmer des objets connectés
un mois j'étais ravi ça veut dire qu'on
allait utiliser les ordinateurs
je pense qu'on fait pas tous les jours
dans toutes les matières et puis
monsieur theron on entend ici nous
motiver un monsieur terran c'est lui le
professeur de technologie premier
enseignant de la région à disposer du
kif
yes we codes des cartes électroniques et
un drone qu'il compte bien mettre à
profit dans tous ses cours et a toujours
une petite partie programmation une
partie virtuelle modélisation en 3d
fabrication
donc c'est de la sixième à la troisième
tout au long des quatre années du
collège dans les mois qui viennent
d'autres établissements devraient
recevoir leur kit d'initiation codage
une entrée en matière avant de passer à
la vitesse supérieure la rentrée
prochaine en septembre
l'informatique et la formation à la
programmation ce qu'on appelle le codage
dans ce projet est bien va se
généraliser à l'ensemble des lycéens de
l'académie
ces collégiens ont juste pris une petite
longueur d'avancé avant qu'une nouvelle
matière s'invite sur les emplois du
temps savoir coder ne sera bientôt plus
une option